FRIEDMAN: Hello, everyone.
Welcome.
It is September 13th, 2022.
We're here at the Active Inference
Institute with John Vervaeke.
So, John, welcome.
Thank you for joining.
I'm very much
looking forward to this conversation.
Hello. And to you.
VERVAEKE: Thank you, Daniel.
It's a great pleasure being here.
Looking forward to this.
FRIEDMAN: Is there any introduction or hello
that you would like to provide
as we head into this journey together?
VERVAEKE: I guess I can give
just a little bit of background
so people know where I'm coming from.
I'm an associate professor
at the University of Toronto.
I'm in I'm appointed both in cognitive
psychology and in cognitive science.
I teach in both,
and I am the director
of the Cognitive Science Program.
So I do a lot of work integrating,
especially psychology
and ideas
from artificial intelligence,
large framework
models, philosophical framework models
for the nature of the mind.
I especially do work on intelligent
and consciousness, insight, flow,
mindfulness and wisdom
all centered upon a notion of,
well, not a notion,
a proposal, a theoretical proposal
that I call relevance realization.
And perhaps we'll get into that
at some point.
FRIEDMAN: Into it we go.
So to provide some context.
These live
streams are multi-directional roads.
We're going to be talking
about different ideas.
For some people,
it'll be their day to day
life and the water they swim in.
For other people,
it might be their first time
hearing about relevance,
realization, or predictive
processing or active inference.
And so we always want
to make it accessible
and also provide depth.
So yesterday
in speaking with some other participants
at the Institute
about how to frame this discussion,
I was bringing
a notion of a three legged stool
and the three legs of this stool
that provided stability
are, again,
those relevance, realization, predictive
processing and active inference.
And then
a participant, Dean, said,
Flip the stool.
It's still stable.
And so that led to some discussions
of what was the between
this of these ideas
and what were they really doing alone
and what did they do together?
And we're going to approach that.
So first, we'll be exploring
relevance, realization
and predictive processing.
VERVAEKE: Mm hmm.
In terms of what they are
and how you recently connected them
in a recent paper.
And then we'll bring in active inference
as a third guest to the party.
But first,
what is relevance, realization
and what is predictive processing?
How did you bring those two together
in the recent work
with Brett Anderson and Mark Miller?
So the two lines were
working independently.
I first got my first paper
officially accepted in 2009,
didn't get published until 2012
because they were holding it back
for a special issue
that took forever to come out.
The reason I mentioned the earlier date
is that's before
I think most of Kristen's
major publications, and that's just
an I'm not claiming precedent
or anything, I'm
just claiming independence.
I didn't know about his work
until after the theory
was well developed,
and I assumed
he might even not know of mine even now.
And that's fine.
So the idea behind
relevance realization
is that
if you take a look
at many different problems
within attempts
to explain the mind in a non muscular,
non question begging manner,
you hit this problem
of relevance realization.
So for example,
how does categorization work?
Well, we noticed
the two things are similar.
What does it mean
to say they're similar?
Well, logically,
it means they share many properties
and then Goodman famously pointed out
that any two objects
share an
indefinite number of true properties.
You know, a plumb and a lawnmower.
Both have rounded shiny surfaces.
They're both found in North America.
Neither one existed
300 million years ago.
Both have an odor.
Neither one is
a particularly good weapon,
etc., etc., etc..
And what people will say to me is
they can't say those are false
because they're all true.
They'll say, But that doesn't matter.
And that's the move, right where you go
from logical similarity
to psychological similarity,
you'd say,
well, I zero in on the relevant
comparisons are and how do you do that?
And that, of course,
is still the crux
of the categorization problem.
Let's take a look at inference.
Well well, inference is just to follow
all the implications of a proposition
in relation to other propositions.
Well, how many are those?
Well, let's take a proposition.
It's it's going to be windy tomorrow
that has you know,
that would have implications for me
if I'm silly,
that are different
for the implications for me
if I'm flying a kite
or if I'm planning to have a picnic
or a planning to stay inside,
or if I'm planning to take an airplane
and do a check out
all the possible connections
between that proposition.
No, I only
select those that are relevant.
And this was a point made very,
very well
quite a while ago by Christopher.
Christopher Chernick in his book
Minimal Rationality,
Problem Solving.
I many of you are already familiar
with this, so I'll just state it.
We know that
the search space for most problems
is combinatorial explosive.
You can't search the whole space,
so you have to somehow ignore
most of the space.
Well, nevertheless, reliably
being able
to solve
a wide variety of problems
in a wide variety of domains,
I can make similar arguments
for communication
and I can make similar arguments
for learning, etc..
I won't go into them.
I'm just giving enough to exemplify that
independently.
All of these things
keep crashing into this issue
of zeroing in
on the relevant information,
and you can you to note it at,
you know, in your everyday experience,
what should you pay attention to
right now?
What should you draw from
working memory?
What should you draw
from long term memory?
Especially with the fact
that you can combine
different things from long term memory?
What sequence of actions
should you perform?
What possibilities
you could consider, etc.?
I take it
that this is at least
plausible enough for me to go on.
People can take a look at
all the publications to see
the arguments more in depth.
So there's crucial ability
for relevance, realization
needs to be addressed
if we're ever going to provide.
I've argued I've argued since my thesis,
if we're going to provide
a naturalistic explanation of the mind
and the read,
which we avoid it,
try to just pretend it's not there, etc.
I think
it undermines our efforts
to give a naturalistic explanation.
Now, this is sometimes
called the frame problem.
I don't call it that anymore
because Shanahan has rightly argued
that the frame problem
was two separate problems.
One was to create a viable logic
for change
that didn't
get you sort of enmeshed in that
and a bleed out
of all kind of identities.
And he argues that that
challenging problem
has largely been solved.
He claims to be
one of the people that solved it.
Nobody seems
to be challenging him on that.
I don't either.
What he says remains,
and that is, are his words not mine,
is the deeper problem of relevance.
That's exactly what he calls it,
the relevance problem.
So this problem is a key problem.
And
I have a proposal that
I've worked on with other people
Tim Little, Blake Richards, Leo Ferraro,
Brett Anderson and Mark Miller
in the recent paper
Gary Hobbesian and a paper
we recently published.
Also Integrating Relevance
Realization Theory
and an inactive
Big Five personality theory.
And the proposal, I mean,
the proposal has more sort
of technical details,
but just to give the idea
and we're not claiming that
this I'm not claiming
none of us
claim that this proposal
is completely novel.
What we're claiming is
you see it implicit
in many different areas
where progress is being made
and you can draw it out
and explicate it and therefore
make more specific proposals
of how to look for it
or how to engineer a mind.
This is the proposal that
the brain basically uses
at many different levels
opponent processing.
And what
it's doing is
it's doing something very analogous
to evolution.
It's opening up variations
and then putting selective
pressure on them.
And then from that,
opening up variations,
putting selective pressure on them.
And you
you can see this
at many different levels.
Your attention is doing it right now.
You default
mode network
is trying to make your attention
wander off and introduce new ideas.
Your task, folks,
its network is drawing it back
in, killing off most of those options.
But one or two of them
might be actually relevant to
what's going on. You keep them.
And the idea is that you do this
and there's many of these trade off
relationships.
I'm just giving one example.
There's many of these trade off
relationships.
They're operating
in a massively
recursive, multidimensional,
self-organizing process
to help you repeatedly zero
in on the relevant information.
Like I say, there's more detail,
obviously,
but that's as fast as I could make it.
A gist of what the theory
is is proposing.
FRIEDMAN: Thank you for the summary.
Definitely a lot there.
In one way,
it's like moving
from the sketch of the continents
and the lay of the land,
the space of the possible
for cognitive science
across these different domains,
and then asking how the relevant
view combinations are selected.
And then one can point to a broad
range of so-called cognitive phenomena
in human
as well as in other cognitive systems
learning, memory planning, attention
composition, ality action,
selection of policy inference.
All of these areas
which one might imagine
could have bespoke custom theory.
Or there might be a way to look
at some similarities, ironically or not,
finding the relevant similarities
in these different cognitive domains
and asking
whether we could improve our inference
and our action regarding those domains
through the usage
of an integrative framework
like relevance realization.
VERVAEKE: That's excellent.
Daniel
And so just to add to why
I think it's reasonable
and perhaps even plausible
that there is such a domain
general central capacity is we have
robustly replicated evidence
for the existence
of general intelligence.
By the way, general intelligence
doesn't mean
it can't be analyzed in components.
It means that it's functional level.
It forms a causal whole
that has no reliable
predictive relations.
And we have it's
you know, it's
the most powerful psychometric
in psychology.
People don't like to hear that.
But it is nevertheless the case with.
And so we have evidence
that there is above all and not in
not in place of
but above all, the specific learning
you have for specific domains.
There is powerful evidence
for general intelligence,
a domain, general ability.
The way we test for it,
Leo and I made this argument
in another paper
is basically
we test
for people's capacity
at relevance realization
again and again and again.
And so
that's why I
think it's plausible
that there is this underlying
capacity.
And what that helps do is it helps it,
it allows you
it allows to bridge
into more comprehensive
of patterns of explanation we have.
So for example,
the model I just proposed to you
is explicitly
an analogy, but a strong analogy,
you know,
to the way
evolutionary processes
produce adaptive morphology
for market organisms,
the evolution variation, selection
and the
and it doesn't require
an intelligent designer.
Right.
Says evolution is clearly a process
that is itself
not intelligent
and can produce intelligence.
And so that gives us
the potential way
out of any homunculus,
our explanations of intelligence
like, you know,
the central
executive selects this or that
and those kinds of explanations
that just presuppose
an answer to this question.
And so instead,
the idea is, no, no, the brain
at this general level, again,
I'm not denying specific heuristics,
although I'm proposing that perhaps
relevance realization
is how those specific heuristics
might be generated.
I'm not I'm not denying
specific heuristics.
I'm not denying
domain specific knowledge.
I'm not denying any of that.
But I'm saying
there is a general ability
just like there is right,
this general process of evolution
for biological activity.
There is this general,
if you'll allow me,
cognitive evolution
of your fitness, your cognitive fitness
as a problem solver to your environment.
FRIEDMAN: Yes.
In those ways, it's
very resonant with generalized
Darwinian models
or like neural Darwinism,
as well as the trend in eco evo
devo ecology, evolution and developments
by way of looking at proliferation
and that pruning back process
in different spatial
and temporal scales, different systems
like the way that it might happen
with synapses forming
and then being pruned
during development.
The way this ecosystem assembly
might occur
with initial plants
forming some sort of substrate
that later forms ground for development,
and then even at slower and longer
time scales
with evolution,
and especially when we think
about the neural aspects,
learning and behavior
are part of development.
They're processes
that happen within a lifetime
and that is a great angle to consider.
So relevance realization
in our first pocket.
Let's move to the second leg.
Predictive processing.
What is predictive processing
and how did it come into play
and why did it
come into play for this recent work?
VERVAEKE: So I've been familiar
with predictive processing
and I would often be an annoyance
that the conferences
were predictive processing
was being presented
because I would ask,
where does the model come from and
where does the innovations
for the model
come from and things like that,
because I was right
and the questions were genuine.
I wasn't, you know,
I wasn't trying to sabotage.
I wanted to understand how this was
integrated and I wasn't getting to
be fair.
And, you know, and the fault is probably
also mine.
You know, I was
I was learning all about this.
I've learned about it quite a bit.
And, you know, and I have my bias.
But Bret Brett Anderson approached me
and he said, look,
I think that what you're doing
in relevance
realization is really needed
for predictive processing.
And then at the very same time, almost
and this is one of those
happy coincidences
that are the shadows of God
or something like that.
A former student of mine
who went through
the cognitive science program.
With me, Mark Miller,
who has work with Andy Clarke
and a bunch of the other
predictive processing
people, came and he said, John,
I want to start working with you again
and I want to integrate
what you've been doing
and I've been doing.
And so
the three of us started talking and
and,
you know,
when we went back and forth a lot
and we came up with
a way in which we saw these
two theories converging.
So predictive processing,
I mean, there's
a lot of technicalities and people
very to the degree to which
they're committed to,
you know, a strong Bayesian
or a weaker Bayesian,
everybody agrees
that you can't be pure Bayes
because it would be
computationally intractable.
You have to do some approximation.
And then the idea is you
have a massively recursive
network
that is basically
doing something really interesting.
Now, again,
not to claim priority or precedence,
but independently in the 2012 paper,
we predicted that the brain basically
tries to model itself in order to model
the environment,
because this actually gets you
through a lot,
passed a lot of difficult problems.
And that was an independently
and again, like
I want to give due credit
that the idea was, no, no,
the brain shouldn't predict the world.
The brain should predict itself
in a multiple recursive
self-correcting fashion
in order to predict the world.
And for reasons
that I won't go into right now,
that just that
that just gets you past
so many of these roadblocks. Right.
And then the idea
is, well, what should the brain
what is the brain doing
when it's predicting itself?
You know,
there's all kinds of math, but,
you know,
a good interpretation is
the brain
is trying to reduce the degree
to which
it surprises
itself, the brain at higher levels.
Well, all right.
You've got a level of the brain
level is meant to be taken
as an abstraction,
not an anatomical region.
There's a level of the brain
that is, you know, doing
sensory motor interaction
with the world.
And the idea is this is a loop.
It's not input output,
it's a continuous loop
where sensation
perception is modifying action
and action is modifying perception.
And so there's
there's a level of the brain
that is just registering
that as patterns of activity
in that causal interaction
and then layers above it, try to predict
how that patterns is going to unfold.
And when there's error,
the error is fed back into that layer
and it is corrected
to try and make a better prediction.
And then what you do is you do this
massively recursively.
You have layers
predicting the layers below them,
so on, and you propagate error up
and you propagate prediction down.
And what that does is it
it allows you to slowly, slowly
hone in on the causal structure
of the world.
And it doesn't promise to get you
the perfect
causal structure of the world
or any Cartesian thing like that.
But what's really interesting
and one of the things
we talked about is,
you know,
you also have that recursive sort
of stacking
of layers
of prediction in various models
of deep learning.
And deep learning also does. Right.
It was one of the inspirations
for relevance realization theory.
It does the variation and selection,
you know, in,
in things like the wake sleep
algorithm, right.
And we thought, hey,
there's a lot of things converging here.
And then, you know,
we started examining this
with other people like Clark, you know,
and we were going through it.
He says, Well, you know what?
What do you predict?
There's there's a combinatorial
explosive number of patterns.
You could predict an environment.
Well, then, you know,
you predict the
the important ones are the relevant ones
or oops, that's going to be problematic.
And then they tried
to predict the reliable ones.
No, that's not good yet enough.
And then you had the idea of precision
weighting
in which you're trying to prioritize
which patterns are given process,
which is basically a model.
And many people explicitly claim
this in the predictive processing
framework of attention.
That's what attention is.
Attention is psychologically
a prioritization process
that's doing the precision
weighting that that helps the,
the predictive processing avoid
the combinatorial explosion.
You can see the convergence
coming in here.
But then, you know, and
fairly recently I think was 2017, 2018,
Clark was talking about this
and he said, well,
precision weighting
also ultimately comes down
to task relevance.
And we and, you know, and
it was like, oh, no, right.
That's just a mankiller.
We we need a little man in there
that's relevant. That's not relevant.
And that can't be it.
And then what
you see is predict
the predictive processing framework
is moving
to trying to come up with sort of
dynamical self-correcting
way in which
the trade
off relationships in the environment
are being used in order to help
trade off relationships. Sorry.
And the way the organism
is trying to survive in its environment
that's more accurate
can be made use of in an opponent
processing fashion to help right
get a non
molecular account
of the precision weighting.
And we saw the two theories as just
oh wow, they're converging,
they're coming right together.
And then it looks like
they could actually help each other.
The relevance realization
can help, you know, explicate
what these trade offs are like
and the kind of opponent
processing make.
And I do mean explicate.
I think this is already implicit
in the most cutting edge work
within precision
weighting and predictive processing
and the predictive processing.
I sometimes like to use this analogy
and don't push it too far,
but I think the predictive processing
is basically giving us
the Mendelian genetics of intelligence
and relevance.
Realization is giving us
the Darwinian evolutionary theory,
and they need each other very deeply.
And there's a lot of things
that the relevance
realization theory
can give to the predictive
processing that it doesn't do
as directly on its own.
These are things like
helping to explain connections
to a lot of phenomenological features.
Salience,
precisely the
the linkage
to theories of consciousness.
I can go into all of this in detail,
and so
the two theories just feed together
and they really strongly
support each other.
I think a very strong advantage
which is coming out now
and this is something
we're just starting to work on.
So I don't have too much to say
that I'm very confident about,
but I'm confident in the intuition
that I will have something to say,
which is that,
you know,
there's been a very strong critique
of the predictive processing
framework coming out of somebody
who I hold in very high regard.
Evan Thompson
And it's complex
and there's an ongoing debate.
I do think that
Evan's main point,
if I can
boil down a very complex argument,
and I hope Evan will forgive me
because I'm just trying
to make
sort of a promise here,
but make it a plausible promise
is that the predictive processing
can be sort of refuted with,
you know, easy
counterexamples of, you know,
pendulum clocks
in training on a mantelpiece
and all kinds of.
So you get you get panpsychism
all over the place.
If predictive
of these predictive processing,
they're supposed to be
the model of the cognitive.
I've heard some
predictive processing people
despite that bullet, but for me
that seems implausible.
I think the answer,
which is
almost the forefront
it in some ways in Evan's point
is that predictive processing
is not really as far as it claims to be.
It's not properly
embodied, embedded
and active and extended.
Now, I think
the way out of that is by
the connection, the integration
with relevance realization theory,
because relevance realization theory
rounds out in the bio economy
of an organism
and it grounds out in the fact
that relevance is always relevant
to a system that is auto poetic.
Montague put it very well.
We're different from computers
in that
they don't care about the information
they process,
we care about the information
we process.
And I propose to you
we care about the information we process
because we are fundamentally
taking care of ourselves.
We are auto poetic beings
and the theory of relevance realization
ultimately grounds out.
It says that relevance is deeper
than representation, it's
deeper than inference, steeper
than logic.
It's actually running off
the bio economics of the organism
and it is working
in terms of the auto processes
and so I think if
predictive processing is integrated
with relevance realization,
it gets very clearly
and explicitly and deeply integrated
within both.
Continue
with embodiment and embeddedness.
And that would address,
I think, many of the criticisms
that are
emerging from
from Evan Thompson's critique.
So that's that's a
so not only
is there increased
explanatory power outward
in terms of explaining
fundamental phenomena, there is a
there's increased explanatory power
in responding to deep criticism.
So that's sort of
where we're at right now.
FRIEDMAN: Amazing.
Many ways to go here
and many great questions
in live chat that I know
we'll be able to get to
one footnote
that we'll come to as well is connecting
so many of the terms
that we're using here,
which are being used
in a technical sense,
scientific or even formal
and mathematical
to their everyday uses
ranging from attention and relevance
to all these different notions
of prediction,
explanation, design, control
and so forth.
So connecting these natural
language terms
to the way that they're used in
cognitive sciences is a very rich area
for the predictive
processing architecture itself.
You absolutely conveyed it, which is it
is building from Bayesian formalism
around inference and uses
a vertical nested model
spatial metaphor.
It's not actually like a skyscraper
or anything like that
where higher levels are making
ongoing predictions
and lower levels are
said to be feeding upwards
observations.
And initially, or at the most peripheral
aspects of the agents
we have
what are most sensory like observations,
but those can become
processed in a predictive framework
step by step,
for example, edge
detection and vision,
object recognition and so on.
And then very interesting
how even at the very beginning
asking how this came about,
you spoke to the way that and Mark
became involved
in this ongoing line of research,
which I think speaks to the social
and action of research
and the distributed
cognitive elements
of development, of theory and practice.
And then to bring to the very end
that the relevance
is a genic and situational.
And that's kind of like the strange loop
or like the quasi tautology,
like fitness
in an evolutionary
setting is situational and it is both
the most mysterious
and explanatory phenomena
and it's the most circular phenomena.
And so relevance as well
is so hyper situational
that it can seem like
it's going to evade generalization.
Yet by combining
computational architectures
which are inspired by both advances
in modern machine learning
and artificial intelligence and deeper
investigations of natural intelligences
of diverse
kinds ranging
from ecological psychology
and all these other fields.
That is what you pointed to in the
in the title
conversion solutions
to the frame problem. And
so anything else
to add
on predictive processing,
relevance, realization
or there and before we add more in.
VERVAEKE: Yeah, I mean, there's an important point
which is important to both Bret
and Mark as well as myself.
I wanted to first of all, try to lay out
what you might call
the scientific provenance
of what we're talking about here.
But now I want to also talk about
a domain in which it offers
significant promise.
I won't go over the argument here.
I've done it in multiple places, both
in many different video series.
I won't even name them.
The point is, in talks
I've given at conferences,
the relevance, realization, machinery.
I think you can make a very
plausibly strong case
because relevance realization
is not cold calculation.
It's about caring.
It's about what grabs your attention.
It's about what calibrate your arousal.
It's about what binds
you adaptively to the environment.
This is about the fundamental
agent arena fitness
that makes you a cognitive agent.
It generates the primary affordances
that are brought
into your cognition
through salience, etc.
What I'm trying to get at is
this is like a promo,
a primordial connectedness
that is constitutive of your agency.
I think
relevance, realization,
and that kind of connectedness
and constitution of your agency
is very much
what people are
seeking
when they're seeking this domain.
General feature of meaning in life.
It's a kind of connectedness.
The language that is used
is mattering, being connected,
the having a fit
between you and the world
that you make a difference, right?
All of this language,
which is almost
always metaphorical, that
in fact
using the word meaning as a metaphor,
we're taking something
from propositions.
We're trying to talk
about our relatedness
to the environment.
And I think
the relevance realization
start relevance realization
when it is giving you
what Merleau-Ponty would call
an optimal grip
and a met
or in fact a meta optimal grip on
the environment
is actually affording that
meaning in life.
That's one point
I want to make another point
that I'm going
to bring the two points together.
So a bit of patience.
If you take a look
at how relevance realization works
and this is one of the advantages.
So I've done a lot of work
in sort of insight and self-deception
that have not been gone
into as much in predictive processing,
you know,
because everybody's doing
what has attracted their interest
and what they
find relevant, to coin a phrase.
But what
what I would say to you
is the very processes
that make us adaptively intelligent,
make us perennially
prone to self-destructive,
self-destructive behavior, because
we are intelligent by
by ignoring so much information,
we always run the risk
that we are actually ignoring
the information needed
to solve the problem.
And you can catch this
in the evolutionary dynamics
of relevance, realization.
When you have an aha moment,
when you go,
you have an insight, you realize,
Oh, I've been I've been framing
this, we'll even sometimes
use that word.
I've been looking at this the wrong way
and we don't need visual perception.
We mean right.
I thought she was angry,
but it turns out she's actually afraid.
I've completely misinterpreted
and you know what I'm talking
about those insight moments.
And that's when the system right.
Is is actually doing something
like punctuated equilibrium,
like an evolution.
But the point is,
we don't always have insights.
We have the opposite of insight,
which is we get locked into blocked
into mis framing situations.
And in itself
deceptive, self destructive manner.
We can do this
individually and collectively,
echo chamber risk, etc.
and therefore
we need
processes that ameliorate
the self-deception without hamstringing
the adaptive relevance
realization
that enhance insight, enhance
that connected.
That's that's meaning in life
while reducing the foolishness,
the self-destructive,
self-destructive behavior.
And I put it to you that across
time and across
cultures, people have come up
with ecologies of practices
for doing that.
And that's what I would call wisdom.
It's a kind of rationally self
transcending rationality
and therefore there are deep connections
that can be made
scientifically plausible,
empirically testable,
and with some of the testing
is already occurring
about central aspects
of what goes into a lot of falls
under the name.
I don't like this term,
but we don't seem to have a better term
for spirituality
where people are primarily
sort of in an often nebulous fashion,
talking about wisdom, insight,
the alteration of consciousness.
And somehow but if you think about it,
a wise person is a person
that can
go into a very messy, complex situation
and somehow zero
in on the relevant information
what really matters
and appropriately
fit themselves to that situation,
to a difference to it in a way that
brings about a movement towards
flourishing for all parties involved.
And so an additional thing
that the connection
to relevance realization provides
that predictive processing doesn't have.
I'm not saying it couldn't have,
but I'm saying this just speeds it up
and makes it is
a connection to a lot of the work
that has been done
by me and others
collecting relevance
realization to meaning in life,
altered states
of consciousness, insight, flow, wisdom.
And that is a powerful way
to extend
the explanatory scope of the theory
while also increasing its existential
and cultural relevance.
FRIEDMAN: Thank you.
Very interesting there.
I want to pick up where you mentioned
this may be towards
what people can be seeking
with questions around life's meaning.
People search for meaning
and you use some terms that are like
things that matter.
And you've brought up in writing
and in conversation
about asking people questions around
what matters
and seeing that as an entry point
into further investigation
as well as like connection and fit.
And you also
brought up from ecological psychology
the notion of affordances,
capacities for action and optimal grip,
where we need to hold
the sports, implement enough to use it,
but it has to be flexible
and adaptive and situational as well.
And this points in our language
and thought
to extensive spatial and visual, visual
and physical metaphors
and figures of speech.
We talk about sketching ideas
and even tangible aspects like
comprehension and grasping ideas.
So we even use this kind of
optimal grip language
around cognitive ideas.
And this is being
dovetailed in a new way
with cognitive physics
and the Bayesian mechanics
that we'll be exploring
more in active inference.
So I think that's extremely interesting
that even the formal isms are seeing
convergence and similarity
in terms of the physicality of things
that might seem
cognitive, mental, abstract,
even spiritual and vice versa.
And I wanted to know where's action
in this picture?
VERVAEKE: So I mean, action
for me is the
how do I say this without I'm
trying to not say
too many things all at once.
There's
agent arena relationships,
set up affordances.
And that's a basic level of relevance
realization, a level I call
participatory, knowing
where the environment, the
the arena and the agent
are co shaping each other
so that affordances open up
and you don't make affordances.
They're not subjective,
they're not in you,
they're not features of the environment.
They're real relations.
I say they're trans,
just genitive relations.
That's when affordances
that we need to open up our ontology.
And this has been a
this has been sort of a philosophical
dimension of a lot of this.
Like we need to
we need to bring back the idea
of real relations
that we've already been implicitly
assuming them captivity is a
is the
is the activity of the great white
shark in the shark.
No, put it in the Sahara Desert.
It dies.
Is it in the ocean? No.
If I put an elephant in the ocean,
it drowns.
Right. So, no, no.
It's a real relationship,
a real relation of fitness.
So we need that.
We need to have an ontology
of real relations.
And so the participatory knowing is
and you remember
this is something
come out of philosophy
is what I'm not I'm trying
not to do too many arguments at once.
You don't have to know,
you know, in order to know,
because if you do that,
you get into infinite
regressions, skepticism.
So these are
this is a kind of knowing
that you don't know that, you know,
because it makes all other kinds
of knowing possible for you.
It's a co shaping by the physics,
by the biology.
Right, but even by the culture
between you and the environment.
So that affordances open up, right?
So agent arena affordances
are there perspectival knowing is
layers up
of recursive relevance
realization in which
the relevance is being translated
as relevance to something like
working memory.
And that's what salience is.
I put it to you
that salience is relevance
to working memory.
I do not think we should be saying
that salience is a property of objects
or a subjective phenomena.
It's that again,
doesn't
ultimately make ontological sense,
but I'll just keep going
perspectival knowing is knowing
what it's like to be you here
now in this state of mind,
in this situation.
And the situation is how the arena is
made afford to you
and your state of mind is
how you are fitted to the arena.
But now you are salience landscaping it.
You are foregrounding and backgrounding.
You are sizing up some things.
You're leaving other things
not as distorted together more penumbra
right and it's dynamic and it's flowing.
You're always salience landscaping
and the function
of that salience
landscaping is to select.
And I mean this like
in an evolutionary sense
to select,
which affordances
are going to be enacted
that your perspective
perspectival knowing
and what it does
when it makes that selection is it
also taps into your procedural
knowing your sets of skills,
your sensory motor routines
for interacting with the
environment, a procedural knowledge.
This is your know how,
this is your knowing how to do it.
And then only
within a subset of your knowing
how you know how
to make certain inferences,
you know how to
make certain proposals
and propositions, etc.
And that's your propositional knowing.
So action is going up that stack.
That's my proposal.
It's the participatory
knowing that is taking up by perspective
of knowing
that is taken up by procedural knowing
that can be reflected
and extended by propositional knowing.
FRIEDMAN: One other
aspect of action which I saw in the
tension
or compromise
between thinking different threads
and only having one mouth
is action is like the eye of the needle
because the embodied entity is able
to only engage
in one action selection at a time
with potentially serious
and even fatal consequence.
VERVAEKE: Exactly. Exactly that.
Take that out.
That's that's important. Thank you.
FRIEDMAN: And cognitive systems
either as if as we model them
or in their actuality can engage
in all of these interesting phenomena
that we've been exploring,
like counterfactuals, planning
all these different aspects that help
one emulate, simulate.
However we want to think about that,
but consider
alternate pasts and presence, which is
like the
perspective,
counterfactual and alternate futures,
which we must engage with to understand
which sequences of actions
we prefer to select.
And then
in predictive processing,
the imperative becomes to,
among other things,
reduce our surprise about the world,
which can be an optimistic model
we're reducing surprise about.
So it's not that we've
expunged pragmatic.
In fact,
we've balanced
in, as we'll explore formally soon,
balanced epistemic and pragmatic value
through actions selection by way
of replacing this
like monolithic reward pursuits
and seeing curiosity and epistemic
as merely like a tributary to reward.
VERVAEKE: Exactly.
And so
that's another that's
that's part of what I met
with the analogy I gave earlier about
genetics and and evolutionary theory
because, you know,
and we're all familiar people
who initially encounter their say,
but I don't want to reduce all surprises
I want
and then
what the typical
predictive processing is.
Oh, but you will sometimes go for
the short term increase
and surprise for a long term reduction.
And then what we're talking about
is overall rate.
But the problem is you
then need something that is selecting
between different
large longitudinal domains of processing
because of course, it's
not always the case
that you should prefer
long term over short term, right?
And there's right
there isn't
there aren't simple
comparative algorithms for this
you need dynamic
tradeoff relationships
between short term, long term between
you know, well, I like some short term.
I don't want
all my short term surprises to go away
because if that was to go away,
then I, you know,
that would impact
greatly on my long
term learning
because I get lock in local minima.
And that's not the only explanation
for curiosity,
but that's that's one
kind of explanation you give
and you go, yeah, right.
But, you know,
that means you can't use
a simple hill climbing.
You got to do other things.
What are you doing?
And, you know, there's,
you know, there's people
there's
people like Bret and I
who think that, you know, there's
there's things happening in the brain,
like self-organizing criticality
at multiple levels of
small world network, organization
of multiple worlds,
multiple levels of wiring
that are trying
to constantly,
dynamically optimize
these tradeoff relationships.
And Chris
Honey has talked
about the fact that you can see
the brain processing at multiple levels.
He actually argues and I don't know,
I don't know
if I completely agree with this.
But, you know, he argues
and I knew that Chris was at U of T
for a while.
He argues that there actually
isn't memory,
there's just different speeds,
longitudinal rates
at which information is being processed,
which is a really cool idea.
And so again,
what this does is soon as you start to
make those
completely legitimate
moves on behalf
of predictive processing,
explaining things like curiosity,
like insight, like wonder,
because wondering curiosity
aren't the same.
Curiosity is there's something missing
and you a piece of information
and you go looking to fill it in
and get rid of your ignorance,
wondering is it was
it was
when you call yourself
and your world into question
in order to set yourself
on to a developmental pathway.
It's an aspirational project and so
predictive processing when it opens up
its theoretical language
in order to address these,
you can see how it starts to lead
more and more into the kind of language
that is afforded
by recursive relevance
realization, theory.
FRIEDMAN: Great.
One closing note
before we move to active inference
is this question of
does the fact that these models
are reducing or bounding surprise
mean I can't have any surprise?
And then that's
there's as you pointed out,
there's various ways to
approach or balance that
critique.
For example,
considering the long term
or the rate of surprise.
And one of the most powerful responses
is nested modeling,
which could be like the self-belief
I expect and prefer
to hear
from diverse and novel perspectives.
Then yes, one will be surprised
in a little sense,
you know, lowercase surprise
by every phoneme,
but then in a deeper sense who we are,
we can be connected
with by hearing new information.
So it's absolutely a valid
critique of the kernel
of a single layer.
Surprise.
Minimize your
just like you would have various
trivial critiques of single layer
reward maximizers.
Yes, or
especially with nested architectures
and considering and hardiness
we can see how higher level beliefs
about the self
which can include like the rhetorical
and the narrative
absolutely provide a context
by which lower level
surprises are accommodated, if
not surfed on top of
VERVAEKE: it.
Just one thing
I think
we can make,
we can even make
some significant progress.
And I did this in a series with Greg
Enriquez and Christopher Masturbator,
the elusive
AI part of
integrating predictive
processing and relevance
realization models
to give an account of the self you take.
You know,
the all the accumulating evidence
that self-reference,
which is really just self relevance,
is the glue of cognition and perception,
relevance, realization.
And then you,
you can basically integrate
that with how we and other people's,
I think it's how we
might call their idea of a predictive
processing model of the self.
And then they just
go together very nicely.
And then you can talk about,
well,
there's relevance,
realization to the self
and this is not just a computer thing.
And you could also point out
the fact that cells are
because we're mammalian primates
and this is Greg's point,
is we learn to turn the irrelevance
the other way.
We we are not just
for our whole development.
How are things relevant for me?
We also develop
how am I relevant to others
and to the world and even to my culture.
And that again starts
to connect up with meaning in life.
How am I connected to
something bigger than myself?
This is the metaphor that people use.
See what I mean?
There's just so many things
that can be brought
into a convergent
and powerful conversation
once we get this integration going.
I'm not saying it's complete,
but I'm trying to at least
make it plausible that it is.
It has plausible promise
to extend
the scope and power
of our scientific explanation
into domains
that it has hitherto been blocked from
getting out.
FRIEDMAN: That's heavy.
That's a massive cognitive entity.
That's groovy.
We're the path of least action together.
Let us move to active inference.
So right in the paper
you mentioned active inference.
One time
though I think we can see it
interwoven densely
and the quotation in the paper
was pointing to subdued at all
times paper.
It has recently been argued
that active inference
and free energy minimization
necessarily entail
the minimization of redundancy
and the maximization of degeneracy.
VERVAEKE: So yes. First.
Just by the way,
I just wanted to highlight
redundancy and maximization.
Just to give another example,
I've drawn directly
from cutting edge biology.
I keep wanting to show again and again
that this is not a trivial
claim of proposed tacit embodiment.
We are making use of fundamental
biological principles.
This is
again
to give a basis for a reply to evidence.
I think that everything that happened
does is brilliant, right?
And so this is but this is again, I just
I just I'm sorry.
I take
I have a deep respect for his critique,
and I just want to keep pointing out
here's a possible response.
FRIEDMAN: Great.
So we have a few
images and pieces of information
about active inference
which we will uncover through action.
We will reduce our surprise about
what is under the gray box
through action.
But first,
I just wanted to hear your perspective.
What is active inference?
How did it come into play
and when
and what
was it doing in your recent paper?
VERVAEKE: So
for me
and I know there's variation
on this between people,
I see active inference
within predictive processing framework
because I see the idea of the interplay
between active inference and perception
and that,
first of all, Mark and Brett
and many of the people that we cite
are not bound to a strict
proposition, final, logical
or sorry
to the logical manipulation
of propositions
when they use the word inference.
If they would do that,
then Evan really does
have a purchase point,
because then they are being
they're being locked
at the propositional
level of processing.
They're
they're not tapping into
all the non propositional,
you know, in a deep way.
But Mark, for example,
very much in active in body
he says we just use inference
because that's was the original term
and it's just stayed as a
as a way of talking.
So the way I think about it is like this
you have two ways of dealing
with the error.
You can change your model
or you can change the world.
And changing your model
is broadly perception.
And I just want to stop here
and open that up.
When we say perception,
we don't mean
what the empiricist gave us
with the sense of perception.
We don't just a purely receptive
bottom up taking in information
because we also mean prediction,
right?
And so
in a very
real sense,
when I'm looking around this room,
I'm not detecting
most of what I'm seeing.
I'm predicting it now.
That does it mean it's an illusion.
True predictions are true.
If you don't believe that you're
you don't believe in science,
you have to give up this sort
of empiricist thing that.
Unless I touched it
somehow in detection, it's not true.
No two predictions are true.
They are real relations.
They are true to the world.
Right. In an important way.
So I would put it to you
that to get closer
to what is meant by perception,
we have to take two terms
that were separated in empiricism
and then put at weird relationship
through the Enlightenment.
We have to actually integrate
imagination and perception together.
You are constantly imagining,
perceiving and perceptive
imagining your environment,
but that doesn't mean it's an illusion.
So first of all, that point right,
and that opens so much up
for explaining the the imagination
and distinguishing
imaginary from imaginal
and all kinds of important
and powerful things.
The other thing you can do is
you can change the world.
Right.
And what and I take it that
active inference is a generic term
for many different species
of how we can change the world,
we can change the world by simply
and we are constantly doing this,
by the way, we can just slightly alter
our perspective again,
the perspective of knowing.
And you're you're constantly doing this.
You're constantly
just shifting your attention around.
So the world is disclosing itself to you
in new ways.
And you
write and you say, Well,
that's just a new way of saying
it's not just a new way of seeing
you are disclosure.
You are look,
you can't ever see all of one object.
You only see an aspect of it
no matter what you're doing.
Yet you think
you're seeing the whole thing
because what you're doing with
this active
inference is you are tracking
and I really want to
play on that sensory motor metaphor.
You are tracking the through line
between all of these aspects.
For me,
that's one of the fundamental things
that active inference means.
It's means that I am look, look at
how I'm doing,
but notice how actually you
how understood, how unsurprised you are
as I do this.
That is.
So the active inference is not just
I make stuff in the world,
it is that too, you know,
I get the water and I drink it.
And so now I no longer thirsty,
but it's even in the it's
even in how you are tracking,
which is an action,
a sensory motor action,
how you are tracking the through line
in the multi aspect duality
of anything in the world.
Because the amount of information
that any object can present to you
is actually called militarily explosive
for me.
Right.
And again,
I'm not denying the gross motor changes
in the world of active inference,
but I'm most interested
in this
cognitive navigation
of the multiuse, factuality
and multiple perspectives of the world
such that we find the throughline.
And here's the thing
that's really intriguing, Daniel.
The through line is not itself
an aspect.
It's not itself a perspective.
It is something that runs through them
and ties them together.
And that is the track
I proposed to you of active inference
at its most primordial level.
FRIEDMAN: Excellent.
I think that golden thread is how
the broader system changes through time,
which we model action as influencing how
things change through time
and the causal structure of the world.
But to pull a step back,
you pointed towards the two ways
that a given agents
can reduce the free energy
of their generative model.
So this is not.
Gibbs free energy.
This isn't
the thermochemical free energy
that causes combustion.
This isn't Tesla Tech free energy.
Though I eagerly await
the day when that synthesis is made.
This is an information
theoretic quantity
that bears resemblance
to the free energy
calculations used in
chemistry and physics and other areas.
And we call that Bayesian mechanics
and the process theory
by which it occurs
being active inference.
And so you point to two ways in which
a given agent
can reduce the free energy,
which balance
the surprise
or with a tractable heuristic
of their generative model.
And those are to change the model.
So change one's self,
and that can subsume an entire taxonomy
of cognitive types and parameters
as model.
They don't have to be a specific neural
anatomical region.
And those parameters
that can be changing
to reduce free energy
of a generative model
can include the continuum of perception
learning
as well as expectation preferences
and also models of action
and the other way
in which
a given entity
can balance their free energy
and seek to reduce
it is through taking action
in the world.
And so
active inference
is built around
the action perception loop
and it gives to meta affordances
for reducing the free energy
by way of minimizing surprise.
So I'm going to go
one more level into detail
with the active inference
by revealing the first gray box.
So this is an image from a recent paper
this year by Chris Thorne
called an informal reconstruction
of the Free Energy
Framework, examining
the conceptual problems that arise.
And the red text
is an additional annotation
that we've added into this
excellent summary figure,
and we can read this figure as being a
perhaps a kairos based historiography.
It's not a literal
chronology of history,
but we can see it
as part of the dialectic
of research progression,
and it begins with the necessity
of learning and developing,
which leads one to adopt a Bayesian
inferential scheme.
My personal preference
is that last names
don't stay attached to terms,
but Bayesian
inference broadly just means models
that update as opposed
to, for example,
descriptive frequentist statistics.
But the necessity of Harris NICS
for Bayesian
inference comes a very early
because exact Bayes is hard
to compute,
especially on large
or unknown state spaces.
The necessity
of Harris sticks
takes a further developmental stage
by the necessity of proxies
that bound the exact Bayesian
or even the Harris stick or approximate
Bayesian solution
and so we can consider
that like uncertainty reduction.
And then this is all pre friston at all
here.
Diane And with Bayesian brain work
and also the work of Hinton and others
in level four where we see
free energy minimization,
free energy minimization
is computational Harris stick
that is already widely in use going back
to Feynman and before to
bound uncertainty
with a tractable computational approach
that includes reducing uncertainty
and kind of being on this perennial
optimal frontier of not
collapsing uncertainty
too much or too little.
And in a way
that's kind of like the energy
and Wolpe term
in the Gibbs free energy world,
except we're in an
informational world now.
So that's
where we were at before the recent work
in the last, say, 10 to 20 years
of especially Karl
Friston and collaborators.
And what Thornton points
to as some of the key
contribution ins that were made
was this
particularly a genetic interpretation
of the lower four levels
by suggesting that
the figure could be separated
from the grounds,
that the generative model
could be separated or partitioned
from the generative process,
which is the niche and that entails
a process theory
which we call active inference,
which is suggesting a synthesis
of inference,
broadly considered,
as you pointed to, and action
and finding all the contact points
and the ways that inference and action
come together
just as the term active
inference would suggest,
which means like action is used
to improve inference, you turn over
the object.
Inference is about action.
It's about selecting action.
It's about learning
the consequences of action
and how conditional
they are on world
states and other
hidden state inferences.
And so the one level
that we can bring in, which
in the active inference textbook
is called the high road
to active inference
is the necessity of persistence
and quite simply, objects
that aren't acting at least
as if they're surviving
will not be around to be observed later.
So whether it's a rock
or whether it's a computer
or whether it's a biological system,
it must at least be acting for the time
that you're observing it or modeling it
as if it is surviving in a potentially
very complex statistical niche.
And so these six levels
do an excellent job of describing
how general statistical
and learning frameworks
like Bayesian
statistics can become improved
and elaborated upon
through computational approaches
which have only been developed,
for example, the Bayesian graph approach
and so on.
In the previous several decades
in the agents frame
directly leads us to considerations
of active inference and understanding
how inference
and self
modeling, including self modeling
about action of the agents,
are a way that either we can either
think of what
agents are actually doing,
or at the very least we can model
what agents are doing through
active inference.
VERVAEKE: Excellent.
I'd like to I don't know. This paper.
It looks like a paper
I would like to have.
So I'll ask you to send me a link later.
FRIEDMAN: Awesome.
So then do you want to add any more?
Or we can go one more level.
VERVAEKE: And I mean,
I think
I don't know if what I'm proposing is a
is an additional level, maybe it is
or maybe it's a way
of adding a dimension
to the highest level
or dimensions to all of it,
or at least
maybe level
seven, six and five
relevance realization.
And, and again, we, we relevance
realization predictive processing
have common ancestors.
Jeff Hinton,
who of course was at U of T
and deep
learning, was one of the explicit things
we drew upon
where we were trying to talk
about relevance, realization
and remember the title of the paper,
Relevance Realization
and the emerging framework
in Cognitive Science.
We were trying to say, look,
there are general strategies
in different areas
that look remarkably similar
and they seem to be strategies
for dealing with this central problem,
a relevance realization.
FRIEDMAN: We could see the organisms
persistence or eco evolutionary fitness
as being like
the environment,
as the selector of relevance.
And then we can think the view
from the inside,
the psychological
or even experiential
aspects of relevance to be a part
that broader system.
And we can imagine kind of two cases.
One is where the
the organisms
experience and cognition
around relevance
is aligned
with ecologically selective fitness.
Yes.
At which case
you're going to find that entity
surviving and thriving.
You can also imagine
where relevance leads us askew
and things become relevance,
whether it's repetitive behavior,
self-destructive behavior
through information
filtering
all these cases
in which our relevance realization
is missing
the mark
it sends with respect
to the ecological selection. Exactly.
VERVAEKE: And that's my point,
how the very process
that makes you
adaptive also
makes you perennially susceptible
to self-destructive,
self-destructive behavior.
You sin, you miss the mark
in a way
that you can't realize you're doing.
FRIEDMAN: And we calibrate
and we learn as long as we are around.
VERVAEKE: Right.
Well,
what I meant
is as long as you're
remaining in your said that it's self
and closes and the other activity
the ability of an adaptive system
to reduce reduced perturbation means
when you have these kinds of parasitic
processing going
on, it hijacks that out activity
and prevents
your attempts
to perturb
it and break and help
you break out
of the inappropriate framing.
That's why you need very comprehensive
ecologies of practices
in order to cultivate wisdom.
It's why simply knowing
that you shouldn't do that
same stupid thing you do
in your romantic relationships
is massively insufficient
for not doing that
same stupid thing you keep doing
in your romantic relationships.
FRIEDMAN: Yes, in the antique framework
with the ecological richness
that is being brought
in, helps us contextualize
and take a pluralistic approach
towards the various kinds
of interventions
which might be suggested,
because interventions
for different kinds of relevance,
you know, mal alignments, self
other perceived in cases
where there's conflict there,
they could include like neurochemical,
it could include an action oriented.
There's so many different ways
in which this nexus of the entity
engaging in inference
and action
can be modified and shaped, that
without integrative models
to help us understand
it can descend into
kind of a disciplinary preference
show off.
VERVAEKE: Yeah, yeah.
The church of the level
I call that
the church of the level of analysis
you believe everybody
should be working at. Yes.
FRIEDMAN: Great.
So let's look at a second aspect
of active inference, which is its formal
basis.
Now, there are many ongoing
developments in the formalism
around active inference
and the free energy principle.
And so this is barely even
the tip of the iceberg,
but hopefully showing these formal isms,
which we explore in much greater detail
in many of the other
several hundred
live streams
that you'll find
at the Active Inference Institute,
just to show a few of the aspects
of the formalism
so people can triangulate
and have a little bit of a sense
for where is active inference between.
So this is from a paper of to Costa
at all from 2020
active inference
on discrete state spaces a synthesis.
So I'll make this image as large
as I can.
There's two key aspects in this figure
the top which we won't go into detail
in, is describing
two types of inference
which are on the bottom
perceptual inference,
which is like a best fitting
estimate for perception
given the sensory data
which are incoming,
which includes the blind spot
and the low resolution
outside of the fovea,
and the lack of color vision
outside the phobia
and all these other attributes
of our
generative model,
such that we even know
that we're
in a generative model and not,
for example,
within some sort of naive
signal processing inward only.
So I see this as just absolute
slam dunk
for predictive
processing architectures broadly
that we don't experience the blind spot,
we don't see it, and that's normal
because our salience
has been tuned down
to blurriness in that area and so on.
And in the top
we have expected
free energy minimization,
which in contrast
the variational free energy minimization
expected free energy is prospective.
It's about selecting expect among
policies, sequences
of action sequences of affordances
that can be expected
to result in different outcomes.
Now the entity could be wrong
and that could lead to the entity
not existing, but within the scope.
The generative model
expected free energy
is how different policies
about one's
own world states
about the Markoff blanket here
which are the set of perceptual
and active nodes
that mediate the interface between
the entity and the niche.
The way that those are
balanced in prospect
ID inference is summarized on the top.
And then it's quite interesting
to look at some of these special cases
on the bottom.
And so we can think about these as like
the Poles
in which
the big tent of active
inference is propped up on.
These are cases
where when one parameter
is minimized or maximized
or doesn't exist,
there are various
special cases that arise.
So just to give a few examples
where there is no preference,
we see information gain maximization.
That's like a pure novelty search.
In contrast, where we have
ambiguity or risk,
so we have complete information.
Then we can engage in classical utility
like calculations.
So that's kind of like
when we don't have to learn anything
or reduce our uncertainty,
then that's a special case
in which pragmatic value alone
can be pursued,
where pragmatic value
has been taken off the table
because all outcomes are equal,
because our preferences across
them are flat,
then the inference can move
into a more exploratory mode
represented by like optimal surprise
or information maximization.
And there are some deeper
and more subtle
links with maximum entropy principles.
But this is just to show
a few of the kinds of formalism
that we explore in active inference
which bring together
many previous threads
in perceptual perceptual inference
as well as inference about action,
for example, from cybernetics,
control theory and so on.
Just a few notes,
and then
one last piece that I think will
hopefully connect us to thinking
about communication, culture,
and then also bridge to the questions
that I've seen
stack up in the live chat.
So these are
from the Active Inference Ontology,
which is a project
at the Active Inference Institute
that we've been developing
for a while over a year now.
And what we have is a
what started as a terms list
but continues to develop
to be much, much more.
And we think of active inference
in building
competency and familiarity
with learning and applying
active inference
in terms
of quite literally skilled
performance of a language.
The terms
and how they're related
constitute
the active inference ontology.
And so two views that speak
hopefully to the directions
that this can help us pursue
rigor as well as accessibility.
Simple English definitions
that link to other terms,
just like you'd see in a dictionary.
A dictionary doesn't
really tell you what the word means.
It just has more words.
Yet It still is considered
a useful artifact
by those who are learning
in applying a language.
And so that's exactly what
our terms and definitions provide,
which are natural language definitions
for some of these terms,
which often straddle the line
or confuse optimally
between everyday usages
and technical usages.
Again, surprise, attention.
All these different terms
which you might hear day to day
being used informally.
They sometimes are used
both in an informal
and quite technical sense
in active inference.
And the second aspect
that's been a great direction and,
and really inclusive
area of participation
is with translating all of those terms
into different natural languages.
So here we see English as well as,
equal partners
with Spanish,
Portuguese, French,
Italian, Czech, Russian, Hebrew, Persian
and hopefully many more to come.
And so by treating
this linguistic artifact
as a collaborative
and participatory projects
and being able
to bring in natural languages
that people have,
as well as bring in computer languages
like our
nomenclature and how we name
computer variables,
we aim for something like a triple play
where we can connect
natural language descriptions
of everyday settings
or of contrived settings.
Those everyday
natural language
descriptions can be visualized
and they can also be rendered
as executable models
because we see that as the promise
of applying active inference
can be most powerful.
When people are engaging in the skills
and in the ways that feel natural
and meaningful to them,
such as in community
engaging in practices
and that is supported and scaffolded in
in feedback
with computational systems
that facilitate the communication and
imagination
around the discussion,
for example, of visualization
and also provide in the same flow
executable simulations.
So it's not just like there's people
who are having a conversation
at the chalkboard
and then the modelers
go take it into a different room.
And that's
where like the alchemy happens.
We think that by connecting the ontology
with natural terms
and computational representations,
that there will be new ways
to be developing
certain kinds
of cognitive
models and infrastructure together.
VERVAEKE: So you're
actually trying to afford wisdom.
FRIEDMAN: What does that mean or
what does it look like?
VERVAEKE: Well, I mean,
insofar as
you're helping people
to apply Sophia into parenthesis,
these are the
two words for wisdom
in ancient Greek,
Sophia, is your knowledge
of first principles.
And from this,
this is how you apply it
within a particular context
so that it is effective,
both giving you virtuosity and virtue.
You're trying to help people
translate Sophia into promises,
which is the sort of meta ability
that is required for people
to be genuinely wise.
FRIEDMAN: With virtuosity and virtue.
I see a lot of
what could be positive
for research and technical areas,
which is
it's not enough
to have virtuosity alone.
Someone can very skilled at taking aim
in a variety of different domains,
maybe one domain, maybe across domains,
but without virtue.
Then
what you have is
skill and capacity, without alignment.
Maybe even the propositional belief
alignment doesn't exist
or it's impossible.
It's useless or worthless
or meaningless.
And then all that virtuosity
to say
it's for not would be an understatement,
because that person
already made that claim.
But it could be worse than for not.
And so.
VERVAEKE: Yeah.
And I want
I want to say
the opposite is also the case virtually
without virtuosity
is something that undermines
the respect that virtue is due
because you have people sort of
attempting by virtue
without having the capacity,
the virtuosity needed
to genuinely empower it in the world.
And so that's also problematic
and so you can get that
you can get the reduction of virtue
to following simplistic rules
or merely
signaling the presence of something
without having the requisite virtuosity
to bring it reliably into being.
FRIEDMAN: How does what you've been working on
points towards or
help us come to terms
with wise technologies?
VERVAEKE: So that's I mean, for me,
I try to take
I mean, a big part of my aware of three
hats.
One is that the scientist hat,
which I've been mostly wearing today
in our conversation,
but I also I also wear a hat
where I help to develop, teach, curate,
create, cultivate
ecologies of practices,
as you said, pluralism.
I wanted to strengthen
the pluralism point you made.
But it wasn't right for me to intervene
at the time.
Pluralism.
I mean,
one of the things that the framework I'm
I'm proposing with, Brett and Mark,
is to note that a lot of relevance
realization and had predictive
processing is taking place
by making use of trade off relationships
between different values
different properties of the environment.
I gave you the upon processing
with the detention,
you can think of the opponent processing
within the autonomic nervous system
for constantly calibrating.
So what you do
is you get a system
that is two systems
that are biased in opposite directions.
One is trying to interpret
everything is threaded opportunity.
Another one is trying to interpret
everything as a safety and recuperation
and they are pulling in on each other
like this constantly.
And that's how your level of arousal
in a non
homunculus
fashion is constantly evolving
its calibration to the world.
So many examples of this, right?
And often in multiple multi
multiple dimensions where
I mean trade off relationships
that are also in trade off relationships
with each other.
That's why
I use the metaphor of an ecology.
If you think of ecology
is all these checks and balances,
both, you know, at the same level
and between levels of organization
and ecology,
there is no panacea practice,
no free lunch theorem, etc., etc.
There is no panacea practice.
They right, you need
you need to get
a dynamic ecology of practices that
well optimizes
for that
multi-layered opponent processing.
And so I try to use
my knowledge as a scientist
to look for places
within traditional
and emerging ecologies of practices
where I can see those design principles
being applied
very well or being developed very well.
And then I help to develop those,
cultivate them,
help build those communities.
And then
that takes me into my third,
which I didn't ever
think I'd be wearing and I'm wearing,
which is
what is it to build these communities
so that
the wisdom of individual cognition
and the wisdom of distributed
cognition are optimal aligned
so that we have the best access
within a community
and then build those communities
into communities of communities.
That's this project that I now
find I'm actually engaged in a lot.
I do not claim to have
any particular expertize for this.
It's just that I have fallen into it
and I seem to be the person
that is undertaking it.
So this one sort of hesitant,
but I'm doing it with other people
and so
the answer to your question is
I wear these three hats
and I try to integrate them
so that they mutually afford
and constrain each other
as much as I possibly can.
FRIEDMAN: Very interesting. A lot to
say.
There
are there's a few ways we can go,
I think let's bring up one topic
and then we'll go
in the end to the questions.
So if have any questions,
please feel free to add them now.
And it's a term that's one of
my personal favorites, which is.
VERVAEKE: Oh, I like these, I like this term.
You introduce the
I did not know this term
until our previous conversation off
camera
where you introduce
this term to me, which I really liked.
FRIEDMAN: It's a great term
arising from work on insects
and the work of Heligan
defines stigma
as a mechanism of indirect coordination
in which the trace left, by an action
in a medium,
stimulates subsequent actions,
stigmatize, enables complex
coordinated activity
without any need for planning
control, communication,
simultaneous presence
or even mutual awareness.
I think it's a
really fascinating and provocative idea
because a lot of times
when we hear about
collective intelligence
or just collective
algorithms more broadly,
there are examples like flocks of birds
which absolutely swarm and flock,
and they use visual coordination,
but they don't leave a trace
on their aerial environments.
Or you have the examples
of traffic
jams of swarms or mobs of people,
in which case, again, there's jostling,
there's contact among entities,
but a trace is not left.
And so those one might think of as like
a live conversation
where no trace is recorded.
And that kind of synchronous
coordination
is absolutely an important component
to consider,
but especially when we think
about at least two
incredibly important cases
which are our digital environments
and the various modifications
that we make to them
and our physical ecosystems
and the kinds of modifications
that are made to these niches.
Neither of those cases
are going to even be hinted at
if we only consider
non stigma, logic,
collective behavior
and collective wisdom.
And so
in some recent work with colleagues,
we've continued exploration
that has been existing
since the earliest days of Wikipedia
and before
around digital coordination
as digital stigma.
G Because
although there are times
for synchronous coordination,
for example, in this conversation
broadly
through all kinds of modifications,
including this video as an artifact
that could be rewatched or transcribed
or analyzed in the future.
Broadly, communication, even
in the online setting,
can be said to result
in complex, coordinated activity
without the need
for planning and control, etc., etc.
So I just wanted to hear your thoughts
on Stig merging.
VERVAEKE: Yeah, that three things
I want to say about that
because it's super cool.
First of all, I for me where
stegeman Jerry
really called out for me is, is how it
affects cultural ratcheting
proposal that
one of our primary capacities for that
activity is cultural ratcheting,
which means
we don't really learn from scratch.
We can't we
we come in
and culture has preserved
previous learning
and then we ratcheted up.
So we culturally ratchet
in a very powerful way.
And so that gives us
a kind of add activity
that is closed off to most organisms.
There are a few
species that you could plausibly
say chimps, bonobos,
maybe some evidence
from dolphins in elephants
where there's something like a culture
at fact, this now
this is where human beings
excel
and stigmatism seems to fit
right in there powerfully.
And you want to
you want to note
that what doing right now
is so, so important
because we're actually where we are
collapsing the boundary that used to be
between live speech and writing,
because we have all the spontaneity
of this,
but then it's preserved
and it can enter into meta dialog
with other videos
where people are moving
between the videos
in dialogical fashion.
And so you get this layering effect,
which is also working
within the cultural ratcheting
and that is very,
very interesting
and needs to be explored.
So that's cool.
And then
I wanted to connect what you just said
with the issue that the neuroscientist
Reid Montague
talks about of mutual modeling.
And this is something that I think
needs to be properly integrated
into this overarching framework
that's being built.
I've done some work,
especially with respect to aspects
of consciousness, mutual modeling.
So
it talks about that you
you faced a certain kind of problem
in communication,
and he calls it
the it's an efficiency paradox.
So the idea is, well,
one of the things
I need to do to increase
efficiency is to reduce
acting at cross-purposes.
So I reduce acting at cross-purposes
by having two or more systems
talk more to each other.
They communicate more.
But another way.
Classically, of course,
by which I improve efficiency,
is I reduce the metabolic costs
or whatever
the costs of my problem solving
and of course communication
is very time and energy expensive.
And so
he says, notice how these and I'm doing
this on
purpose are in a tradeoff
relationship, right?
The more we communicate,
the more we increase our costs
and we lose efficiency,
the more we reduce communication,
we reduce our metabolic costs,
but we increase acting at cross-purposes
and our efficiency also goes down.
How do we solve this?
And then he gives
he gives a wonderful analogy
before he moves to brain and he says,
well, consider
an old married couple happily married.
Some people stay married
because they hate each other,
and that's the best way
they can torture each other.
But I'm talking about
people who stay married because they
they they are love.
They have almost like this telepathy
with each other.
And he
didn't quite use this language,
but he uses the language of modeling.
But I think calling it
generative modeling
is no imposition on him.
And he says
his his example is straight as to like
a straight relationship.
I'm just going to use that
for ease of reference.
I'm not prioritizing,
not making any cultural claim.
I'm just saying
it's easier to talk
because I can just quickly use
common language, right?
So the husband.
Right, has
a generative model of his wife
and the wife has
a generative model of the husband
so that they can actually
coordinate their behavior
without having to talk to each other
very much.
So that's what he leaves it.
Now, what I argued is kinder.
That's right.
But you have to cycle
because periodically
they have to come back together
and talk to each other
right to make sure their model,
the general models
aren't getting out of whack
and then they can go off
and do their coordinated
on communicating behavior
and they cycle.
And then I said you can
you can actually see the brain
doing this it
how you do the task focused
where you're processing all the world
and you coordinate
all these different areas of the brain
are coordinated
without having to communicate
much on the task.
And then you go to default mode.
Where what are they doing?
Well, they're all centrally hubs
and they're all checking in
with each other
because you
you just do all this sort of,
you know,
self-referential imagination,
making sure all the models are in sync.
And then you go back on the world,
you know, sync up again,
go back on the world, sync up again,
all these trade off relationships
and how you resolve that.
The paradox
and then I thought you know
mutual modeling and stigma
like they really belong together
as underlying concepts.
Now Montague's argument is
you see the brain
adopting this strategy,
you see the brain doing this, all right,
where you've got areas
are are engaged
in generative modeling each other
and think how easily
this could fit in to predictive
processing framework because you're
there's areas of the brain
are predicting other areas but the idea
and then you know
you can point to evidence of synesthesia
across model enhancement of perception
the fact that one
supposedly specialized area
like acoustics can actually take over
sight in people that teach blind people
who teach themselves
echolocation, synesthesia,
a whole bunch of other things
just pile up
as evidence
that the brain is
adopting that strategy.
And so I thought
this was an interesting thing
because this notion in one sense
points to cultural ratcheting and stigma
and mutual modeling between people,
but it also points inward
to mutual modeling within the brain.
And like I said,
I think this is so close
already to a lot of what's going on
in the framework we're talking about.
They're bringing this in and then again,
then we could extend the explanation
to things like synesthesia that.
You could get cross modal enhancement
that you can have one
area of the brain
supposedly
dedicated to one sense modality,
picking up the ability for right
in rehabilitation, etc., etc., etc..
FRIEDMAN: Well to two layers of marital
stigma e.g.
the first would be the neuro
anatomical stigma e.g.
by which local synaptic changes
and other sort of neuro
architectural changes
enable complex coordinated activity
without the need for a central neuron.
So at the micro scale
we have the physicality of learning.
And then
there's the Post-it note
and there's the note on the door,
there's the modification
of the environments
which is stimulating subsequent activity
and it doesn't need to be
the recipe for dinner.
It can just be a note or an inside joke.
And so when we have a model
that's integrative
and allows us to situate
advanced cognitive agents
in their niche,
then we can actually bring
in those kinds of modifications,
which is the root of stigma
due to mask stigma,
not in a taboo way,
but to mark the environments
and the ways that
that can elicit action,
whether it's, again, a Post-it
note on the door in the relationship
or a comment on a video.
So these are all ways
that we can spur others to action.
VERVAEKE: Or and so you can just
when you can take
the mutual modeling idea
and then do George Herbert Mead, you're
right.
You're in a baseball
you're on a baseball team.
And you don't
necessarily need
to form a specific model
of all the other players.
You might want to have that a bit,
but you can, he said.
What you do
is you create the generalized other.
You create a model, right,
which will allow you to interact
with all of them very effectively.
And so right.
We can carry around.
We can like we can have stockings,
we can have more specific mutual models
for how I relate to my partner.
But then they in a right dynamic
recursive relationship
with a generalized other model.
And that also is a trace of others
like the guts of our cognitive
modeling in a very, very powerful way.
FRIEDMAN: Yes, multi-player rituals
as cultural ratcheting
in more people
to be involved in cumulative
as well as re-experience
and reimagined cultural practices and.
If there's a level to generalize out to,
perhaps it is one of them
that is relevance
such that
we can have participatory ritual, as
one can say every single culture has,
but taking awareness
and wisdom into the process
of shaping our rituals
so maybe they can be aligned
with our preferences.
VERVAEKE: That's exactly right.
And there's a whole movement
and I'm involved in it.
And I spoke to this
at a recent invited lecture
I gave at Cambridge
about ritual knowing and the connections
between ritual,
the imaginal and being rational.
And so very much,
very much
I you allow me,
I'll give you one instance of this
and think about how this
goes to updating
and all the stuff
we're talking about
in predictive processing
and reducing surprise. Okay, stuff.
So
you go into academics
who are supposed to be the cream
of, the crop.
So a little bit of
self-deprecation there and
you give them convincing evidence
locked salt,
you know,
rigorously tight arguments
that they should start saving
for their retirement.
Now you allow them to raise
whatever objections they have.
You meet them.
You get them to all agree that.
You've convinced them
that they should save
for their retirement.
You go away,
you come back in six months.
None of them are saving
for their retirement.
Hyperbolic discounting, etc., etc.
Hyperbolic discounting
is an adaptive thing, etc.
I won't go into all of that. Right?
But then when you do and there's like,
you know, Hirschfield
and other people all this,
what you do is you do something else,
you get them,
and this is the imaginal, not imaginary.
You get them to
imagine their future self
as a family member
that they have a responsibility for
and that they love
and they want to give
the best possible life to
two things you find when you come back
six months
later, the people that did
the do the imagining start to save
and the more vividly they can imagine,
the more they save.
So you overcome a kind of egocentric,
hyperbolic discounting through
and in in in imaginal.
It's basically a ritual,
this imaginal binding of
to your future self so that you get
a more adaptive relationship.
FRIEDMAN: It makes me think about variational
free energy,
which is about the present in the past
as religion religare
and then expected free energy
as pre the glory because.
We need to bind ourself to futures
that haven't happened.
Yeah, there's an aspect there.
VERVAEKE: There's a there there's there's a,
you know,
there's a current, a genetic
right way in which religio
that's my preferred
etymological origin for religion
binding connectedness
and there's also aspirational religio
and what it religion often does
is try to trade it
try to find a sweet spot
an optimal relationship
between current and aspirational religio
FRIEDMAN: mazing.
Let us
look at some
of these comments so any of them
feel free to add comments
or give a response.
So first, Ali has written
in to lose his words.
Relevance questions are how much
and how.
In what cases
and who questions, as opposed to
what is X questions
from difference in repetition?
So what are the questions
that bring us towards relevance
as opposed to questions
that make relevance obscured?
VERVAEKE: That's a really interesting question.
I'm not I don't know much to lose.
I read a little bit about Deleuze
and that's
I should read more Deleuze
because I'm a deep fan of Spinoza
and he has a very interesting reading.
I have the book
My To Lose on Spinoza, but
I am really hesitant
to give much of an answer here
because I don't know Deleuze very well.
FRIEDMAN: It doesn't have to be a dull
Lucien answer
just what kinds of questions and and
interrogate interrogative
help us find both and.
VERVAEKE: So I think that I want
to collapse a large argument built
from Sperber
and Wilson
and their work
on a book
entitled Relevance,
by the way,
at least within communication.
I think
this is where I disagree with to lose,
but this is why I hesitate
because I don't know.
Deleuze Well, so that's my hesitancy.
I think all of the questions
are ways
of trying
to get a reformulation
of what we find relevant.
They bring out that
they bring out different
bring in different perspectives
and point the arrow of relevance
in different direction.
And what Sperber and Wilson they took,
they said, okay, you know,
you have the pragmatic
of all communication.
What's pragmatics?
Pragmatics is what you convey
beyond what you can say,
because I can't
actually put into my words
every all of the information
I'm trying to convey to you.
Because if I if I did that well, if
if and by the use of
if I'm making use
of not the logical F,
but the temporal and conditional,
if I in this case, I'm referring to me
and I'm referring to me insofar as I'm
in this current situation.
Did that
and that was
referring to
what of all the things I've spoken of,
I'm speaking of
a, you know,
trying to give this specific
verbal form of everything
I'm trying to convey.
And then for each one of those,
what do I mean by the current?
You see what happens.
You get a penumbra
of ever expanding attempts
to get you to translate the conveyance,
and you get a combinatorial explosive
list of sentences that I can't say.
And you do.
You do all the time.
You know,
you drive up
and you open your window
and you say, Excuse me, I'm out of gas.
You mean your car is out of gas?
You're not trying to be more flatulent.
You mean
gas is actually standing for gasoline?
You mean you're
not completely out of gas?
You have some
you can drive
at least a few more minutes if you're
right.
And you know, all of
these things are at work
because if you violate
any one of those expectations,
you get pissed off.
If they say to you,
there's a gas station at the corner
and you drive to the corner
and the gas station has been closed
for ten years, you don't go, Whoa.
Well, he told me the truth
because you write,
it was conveyed to you
that you could make use
of the gas station
because you're out of gas.
I won't go on to that.
I'm just trying to give
an intuitive example.
And so Grice gives these four maxims
that we are trying to always follow
where in order to manage the conveyance
so it doesn't become
combinatorial explosive
and it's the in its manner
and formats and what is quality.
So he gives three that are not relevant
and the fourth one is relevance
explicitly.
So and then Sperber and Wilson
just basically argue
all the other ones
collapse into relevance
like quality is tell the truth.
Well not no don't
tell the truth
you don't tell everything
that's in your mind
when you're speaking to somebody
you select
out of all that that's in there,
a subset that's relevant.
So give the relevant truth,
the relevant manner, etc., etc..
So we always are doing this
and I think questions actually operate
right primarily at the pragmatic level.
Of course
they have semantic consequence,
but what we're constantly
doing is asking,
which what are you
conveying and what are the
which are not the same
thing as implications?
What are the relevant implications
before I try and derive the implications
of what you're saying,
that's what questions I think do.
Now,
I want to also be clear
about this, that
we need to be directing
the questions into directions.
Sometimes we are probing our
we ask sexualizing, framing the arena.
Well,
in terms of
is the world we check to see
is the world disclosing itself to us
such that we are solving
our problems and flourishing.
But sometimes we also need to step back
and look at the framing itself
and ask, Is the framing
right actually misdirecting
or misleading me?
So I think questions are always
trying to reconfigure the fitness.
And one of the things
we and therefore
they're trying to enhance
relevance realization
at the pragmatic level.
But we should always remember
to direct the questions
in at least these two directions.
FRIEDMAN: Excellent.
Thank you.
All right.
Here's a question from Brock.
Can you give some examples
of how depending
on ignoring to realize relevance
can prevent realization of meaning?
Does this relate to reciprocal narrowing
and opening.
VERVAEKE: Yes, yes, totally.
And so Brock is familiar with my work
and I'll just let me just quickly open
those the
those final things up
so other people are aware
of what he's alluding to.
Thank you for doing that.
So the notion of reciprocal
narrowing is drawn from my friend
and colleague
Mark Lewis, who has proposed
a learning model of addiction
rather than a disease model
of predicting of addiction.
So our current model,
which governments and agencies
like, is that the disease model?
You have this thing, it's infected
you and you're trying to like
and it's it's debilitating you.
Now,
I want to make something very clear.
Mark is not saying
that there is not a neurochemical layer,
but he's trying to
while he's trying to get
an insight, he's
trying to get you to realize
that the disease model
makes all kinds of predictions
that have been empirically
just confirmed.
I won't go through all of them,
but they have to do with the fact that,
you know, when we have that model
will tend to think
the substance,
as in and of itself, addictive.
You know, cocaine is so addictive.
Heroin is so addictive.
Well, you know,
yet there was lots of soldiers
in Vietnam using opioids.
And when they came
back, the vast
majority of them stopped
without having
to have any special treatment.
They stopped using opioids.
But opioids are so addictive.
Well, what's different
because I ask you that presumably
this destructive
the chemical structure of heroin
in Vietnam, in
the United States is the same.
What is different?
The agent arena
relationship is different.
You're a soldier
in a traumatic circumstance in Vietnam,
the United States,
you're a citizen and you're not.
And of course, that
caused all kinds of other problems
for these people
because the agent arena
relationships are so different.
Here's what Mark proposes.
So let's
all use alcohol
because it's
one people can easily relate to.
I have a very challenging arena
and I'm stressed.
So it takes some alcohol
and it reduces the stress,
but it actually limits
my cognitive flexibility.
So my problem solving abilities go down.
So the options available to me
in the world goes down.
So the world narrows.
As the world narrows,
it becomes more stressful to me.
So now I want to take more alcohol
to keep the stress away,
but that's now impairing
my cognitive flexibility.
You see what's happening.
The world as an arena is narrow
and my capacity
as an agent is narrowing.
So you've got reciprocal narrowing
until I can't be any other than I am,
and there is no future for me at all
other than this moment
of taking the drug.
And that's addiction.
It's reciprocal narrowing.
Now, I was literally Daniel,
I was literally at lunch with Mark Lewis
and I said, But Mark,
if there's reciprocal narrowing,
there has to be reciprocal opening.
And he went, Oh, you're right.
And I talked about
how Plato talks
about this in the model of
what's called and again,
the his model in the Republic
of how you ascend out of the cave into
seeing the real world
reciprocal opening. And so
I think when
we engage in
ignoring
relevant information,
we will often very readily fall prey
to a very powerful kind
of reciprocal narrowing.
So let
let's let's go back to the example
I used.
You don't have the insight.
You think she's angry
when she's actually afraid?
You don't have the insight.
And so you push on her
and you only take evidence confirming
confirmation bias
that she's angry in to your model
and then you only act towards her
as if she's
and she's going to start probably
almost like a self-fulfilling prophecy,
respond more and more
because your anger, right,
you start to act towards her
in a way
that gets increasingly aggressive
and you whisper darkly narrow,
and then it gets harder and harder
for you to see that she's not angry
and it gets harder for her
not to communicate to you
in a way that you have to interpret.
His anger.
Because when she tries
to give you something else,
you ignore it in zero.
And you have been in arguments
and fights like this
at some point in your life
with somebody
that you don't want to be severed from,
but that kind of
thing can sever that connectedness.
And when you're at the end of your life,
you don't really care
how many objects you've manipulated.
You don't care
how many french fries you eat.
You care about the relationships
you had and how deep they are.
And if you didn't pay attention
at that time, you lost a relationship
and severed a connectedness
that enhances your meaning in life.
You've
you fell into reciprocal narrowing.
It severed a relationship,
and your connectedness
mattering to another
human being has been lost.
FRIEDMAN: There's no more interpersonal gravity
and the relationship does not matter.
VERVAEKE: Yes. All right.
FRIEDMAN: I'm going to read just a few
non question comments
and then get to a question
in these last minutes.
So Griswold wrote, Ants
hold hands in the river of information
to float along together.
VERVAEKE: That's wonderful.
FRIEDMAN: Ian wrote
Vision and
fusion communities coupling
and decoupling and imagination
in as our static
remembering of the future.
VERVAEKE: Oh, wow. Nice.
FRIEDMAN: Very cool.
All right.
And here's one more question.
This is from Dave.
So Dave says, have you found
oh, I don't know
if this is the correct way
to pronounce the name, but Giles
FALGUNI Ayres
work on mental
spaces and conceptual fusion, useful
in explaining
and improving the evolution
of concrete mental activities.
And we can also see this work on
generalized space
and navigation
with Chris Fields
and Mike Levin and many others.
So whether you're familiar
with that researcher or not,
how does this idea of cognitive spaces
help us
work in physical and social spaces?
VERVAEKE: For me,
again, and this how,
you know, the connection
to relevance realization
and its connection
to connections to biology
and evolutionary modeling
is really helpful here.
So me a moment and then I'll.
So one of the ways
in which evolution selects is it accepts
expectation means
it doesn't have to
generate an entirely new mechanism.
And so let me give you
a concrete example.
It's one of my favorite ones.
What I'm doing with my tongue right now
is speaking.
Of course,
times did not evolve for speech
because we have so many organisms
that have tongues
and they aren't capable of speech.
But what does the tongue do?
Well, it helps Master Kate,
so it has to be highly flexible.
It has to be a poison
and calorie detector.
So it has to have lots of nerve endings
and it has to be
it's in the air passageway
because that's how we evolved right.
So it's it's almost predesigned.
It's some people say pre adapted
for speech
and so it gets exact it into speech.
I think there's growing evidence
look at barbecue verses
book mind in motion that the brain
and this goes to the work
of Michael Anderson and the and others
the brain is an executive
process of the brain
is constantly exacting
machinery that
emerged one
arena set of actions for another
specifically it looks like
the set of abilities that we generate
for navigating
physical space is exacted into moving
around in conceptual space.
The fact that we have been calling it
conceptual space
and we talk about things
being higher and lower
and we move between,
etc., you can
it's just it's
just totally impregnated
with navigational language.
And we talk about orientation
and finding our way or losing our way.
I Can you follow this argument?
Well, that's tracking language.
Can you follow this argument?
Where is it going to? Right.
You know, I lost the thread of what?
Just like again
and again and again and again.
And and so it really
and it helps to explain
really weird stuff that's otherwise
not well explained.
Okay.
Cerebellum
More neurons than your neocortex,
often
not included in F memorized, by the way,
which is a mistake
in a mini f memorized
I think should be removed their findings
because the cerebellum is not included
and we we are now getting overwhelming
evidence for the cerebellar
cerebellum cortex loop.
And by excluding the cerebellum
from our f of our eyes,
we are
we are we are smuggling in a confound
that has not been properly
controlled for
so just a general point there,
when people are sitting in a
what's the cerebellum for,
you know, sensorimotor balance, right,
then people are sitting
absolutely still eyes closed,
perfectly stable in meditation.
Their cerebellum is firing like crazy.
Why
they're not doing anything.
They're not moving.
They're in a position
where they can be deeply comfortable
because they are aligned with gravity
and like they're stable, stable, stable.
Their eyes are
well, presumably
because they are navigating
and they're trying to balance
complex contingencies of attention
and move through the experiential space
in a powerful way.
And the cerebellum
this when I started talking about this,
it was controversial.
Now it's approaching consensus position
that this is
the cerebellum
has been exacted
for these kinds of functions.
So I think the idea that
we but that
and I'm not
I've only briefly looked at
Fukunaga's work
when I was doing work on metaphor,
I didn't find it
particularly helpful for metaphor,
so I didn't go into it more deeply.
But the the idea that we are doing
something like mapping between spaces,
I think this is
I think yeah,
I think this just plugs
into the exhaustive nature
of our cognition
that it is a form of rapid cognitive
awesome.
FRIEDMAN: Well, in the final minutes,
do you have any words of wisdom?
Any thoughts?
Where do we go from here?
Where do people go from here?
VERVAEKE: Well, it depends.
I mean, you can go theoretically
in which you can look
at my publications and
and Mark is coming.
He got an amazing grant
and other grants. And
so he's come maybe you to
he and I are going to do work
Brett and I are doing work.
The three of
are going to continue to work.
So look for that.
Gary and I, who published the paper
on relevance, realization
and personality,
have one
pretty well-written
on integrating relevance realization
and attachment theory
in terms of attachment is actually a
an optimal gripping practice
between the child and the mother
or frequently
the mother, the
the primary caregiver, I should say.
And so you can look for all of that,
for of you
who are interested
more in the wisdom stuff.
You can look at the stuff
I published on wisdom
some.
I don't think I wrote
any wisdom papers on my own.
There are with other people
you if you're interested
in mindfulness,
I've got two publications, one on
an Oxford book, the anthology
edited by Amir
RAZ on hypnosis
and meditation,
and more recent one
which I recommend in the Routledge
Handbook on the philosophy
of meditation,
where I talk about all of this.
I think how this all works out
in terms of attention
and meditation and contemplation,
why they're not the same thing,
why they're an important
processing relationship,
why that's conducive to
insight and more
systemic and systematic insight, etc..
If you're interested in learning
about the meaning crisis,
you can go to my YouTube series,
Awakening for the Meeting
Crisis and follow that argument
all the way through.
I have a new series
coming out
which is about trying to tap into
how we can afford
these kinds of flowing,
emergent conversations
that take us
beyond where we can go in
an individual cognition and empower us.
And it's called
After Socrates, where
I'm tracing out
what's going on
in dialectic into the logos
that's coming out
this year, probably October, November.
Rebel Wisdom.
David Fuller
They're making a documentary film
about my,
me and my work
that's coming out also October
and November of this year.
So that's a bunch of things
you can look for and look at.
FRIEDMAN: Amazing.
Well, thank you
very much for joining us.
You're always welcome to come back.
We really appreciate it.
VERVAEKE: Thank you so much, Daniel.
And thank you so much for
I mean, you there's a couple of things.
Maybe if you sent me
your slides or something from this site,
that would be great
because there's a couple of papers
that I want to read now
and that is excellent.
It was genuinely back and forth and
I appreciated your insight
and your perspective a lot
and also your graciousness.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
FRIEDMAN: Thank you, John.
Till next time
VERVAEKE: they could.
Thank you, everyone.